donc
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale des échecs
unissions spécialité spécial
décontractée avec le grand maître le
plus bronzé du circuit j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir mené côté jean-luc chavanon
bonjour jean luc bonjour et loi alors
l'été et les échecs
qu'est ce que ça donne envie d'aller
jouer un tour nos familles en vacances
sur la côte d'azur
il ya énormément de plomb évidemment
donc en france il ya plein de tournois
donc qui est qui corresponde finalement
à tous les goûts des taux - de très haut
niveau des tournois un petit peu moins
forts mais dans des cadres toujours très
agréable et très variée surtout
d'ailleurs dans le sud le sud est un
lieu vraiment privilégié pour tous les
tournois
il ya donc la gueule en mode cannes par
exemple celle tombée il ya tant de
marseille
il y en a beaucoup beaucoup on va
d'ailleurs donc tous voulaient détaillé
mais avant de vous en dire plus je vous
invite à aller sur le site de notre
partenaire donc www.fff.fr check point
com c'est donc le site de la fédération
française d'échecs vous cliquez sur les
annonces de tournois et là vous avez
tous les temps de l'été donc tout pour
trouver le tournoi qu'il vous faut si
vous avez envie de partir donc tout de
suite on va détailler un petit que les
tournois qui ont eu lieu en essayant de
vous faire apprécier l'ambiance et
ensuite on vous indiquera les tournois
où il faudrait aller donc jean luc
tournoi de marseille il ya lieu qui
compte fin juin et qui termine début
juillet donc c'est un nouveau tournoi je
crois c'est la deuxième édition du
tournoi de marseille donc bon on peut
dire que cette année ça valait le coup
d'y aller parce que
marseille ça va être la ville
organisatrice des championnats de france
et c'est une ville qui bouge beaucoup
une région qui bouge beaucoup donc pour
les échecs et donc
des dirigeants qui sont très très
sympathique aux mêmes dates
il est également le tournoi de hand or
en dehors on sait que ces frontaliers
entre l'espagne et la france s'est à
moitié une principauté on est une
communauté on sait pas trop à qui ça
appartient mais ils organisent tout le
temps donc fin juin début juillet un
très forte en a il y avait cette année
alexei shirov qui a joué donc en dehors
est ce que tu es déjà allé j'ai joué en
dehors mais je n'ai pas joué cette
compétition là je sais que c'est une
compétition de très haut niveau
en tout cas bon endorse situé en plein
coeur en coeur des pyrénées c'était un
cadre magnifique et le noter qu'il ne
fait pas trop chaud en andorre ça c'est
important quand même jean-luc eux
puisque justement c'est à la montagne
que le tournoi se joue quand même c'est
chaud calée au mois de juillet mais
c'est quand même un endroit magnifique
et où on peut jouer des parties de très
très haut niveau
thomas original également qui commence
le 1er juillet donc à naujac-sur-mer
c'est clair qu'en fait on appris la
liste de tous les temps - et on vous
comment tu n'es plus intéressants les
grands classiques donc non jacques sur
mer a une particularité jean-luc ça se
joue dans un camping et le premier prix
il est curieux et we don't know jack
naujac-sur-mer donc ça c'est un grand
classique des tournois français
c'est un tournoi où le vainqueur se voit
donc gagné donc son propre poids en vin
voilà donc original à tournoi original
qui évidemment on rencontre des maîtres
et grands maîtres qui vont de temps en
temps par type et ce tout en un qui est
devenu c'est devenu un véritable
rendez-vous des échecs et de nombreux
professionnels s'y retrouve
rendez vous grand rendez vous de l'été
côte d'azur toujours tournoi de
montpellier
jean-luc là c'est le premier des grands
classiques de l'été
voilà donc le toit de montpellier qui
est organisé depuis plusieurs années
c'est un grand classique s'est organisé
tout près de de la place de la comédie
donc en plein centre ville donc
montpellier c'est une ville
très sympa et le tournoi est très très
fort dans notre effort puisque cette
année il y avait laurent frayssinet
hicham hamdouchi luc bergez bon marc
santoro mans il y avait également gonflé
regagner le temps m'a donc beaucoup de
grands maîtres tournoi très conviviale
très sympathique qui vient de se
terminer donc fière victoire de glem
flir laurent frayssinet plus en forme
donc ça serait plutôt dans les résultats
de tournoi mais si vous voulez de
l'année prochaine ou alors si vous voyez
cette émission différé l'année prochaine
et bien pensé aller jouer ce tournoi
montpellier qui est vraiment un des
tournois les plus sympathiques dans
l'enchaînement de montpellier donc après
le montpellier terminant le 12 c'est à
dire aujourd'hui il ya le tournoi jean
luc très intéressant et très sympathique
conviviale familiale de temps à de
saint-affrique le trafic donc c'est un
très très grand classique donc le combat
de saint-affrique
contrairement à son nom ça se situe donc
dans l'aveyron donc ça se situe pas très
loin de millau donc tout près des caves
de roquefort dans les montagnes les
joueurs sont très très forts et
l'ambiance est très sympathique c'est un
turnover
c'est un tournoi wii qui est qui et dans
le centre de la france et je conseille
donc ce tournoi
c'est peut-être amené à vous aurez
l'occasion de voir là bas par exemple
didier colas qui habite sur place qui
entraîne le club de saint-affrique
ça commence le 21 juillet donc il n'est
pas trop tard pour vous inscrire pour
tous renseignements www.fff.fr chaque
avec un s évidemment et là vous pouvez
encore vous inscrire pour le tournoi de
saint-affrique qui est donc un tournoi
très très sympa aux mêmes dates le
tournoi de avoine alors jean-luc il se
tourna de avoine il est particulier
qu'est ce qu'on peut en vient donc le
tournoi d'avoine et particulier beaucoup
d'animations sont faites pour que les
joueurs puissent passer donc une semaine
une semaine très agréable axée sur les
échecs et sur le sport et sur le sport
donc il ya la possibilité de faire
différentes activités sportives et aussi
des dégustations de vin puisque avoine
se situant près des des caves de chinon
il est possible donc de 2
de s'initier à la le nos logis donc si
vous êtes fan de vin et bien le tournoi
d'avoine est fait pour vous il ya
également du tennis et le tournoi de
prédilection de manuela pis c'est là
qu'il était champion de france aux 92
donc qui va tous les ans jouer ce
tournoi de avoine 21 juillet au 29
juillet donc s'il a la particularité
d'être on s'attend à une partie longue
comme tout ce qu'on a mentionné ici jean
luc c'est à dire que le tournoi s'étale
sur une semaine
on joue une partie par jour qu'on est
donc totalement détendu on a toute la
matinée et toute la soirée on joue
l'après midi donc voilà tournoi de
avoine très sympa autres banques
grand classique mais cette fois ci qui
s'adresse principalement aux
travailleurs puisqu'il est en horaires
de nuit si je puis dire c'est le
championnat de paris du 21 au 29 juillet
cette année y aura laurent frayssinet en
stars du tournoi est également jean-luc
un participant bronzé puisque je crois
que tu vas prendre parti dans cette
épreuve
effectivement donc le championnat de
paris ce sera un test ce sera un des
tournois les plus forts de cet été
puisque laurent frayssinet christian
bauer vont jouer de nombreux grands
maîtres internationaux et et moi même
donc allons participer à cette
compétition
ça va être
du beau jeu et une cadence un peu nos
questions c'est vrai c'est un peu
difficile pour les professionnels mais
pour les gens qui travaillent c'est
quand même très pratique
alors attention c'est un tournoi où il
faut avoir les nerfs solides puisque
vous les parties à 19 heures elles
peuvent se finir à 23 3 heures du matin
en tout cas c'était comme ça l'année
dernière
la salle est très chaude en général il
ya 600 700 joueurs donc si vous avez
envie de jouer un tournoi d'échecs à
paris qui soit compatible avec des
horaires de travail et bien le
championnat de paris qui commence le 21
fini le 29 est fait pour vous pour plus
d'informations vous allez sur notre
autre site partenaire www.socgen.com qui
donc le site internet
échec de libération et là il vous aurez
beaucoup plus d'informations jean luc tu
vas nous arrivons à ton tournoi de
prédilection puisque c'est le tournoi de
cannes côte d'azur tu es cannois ont tu
étais au vernis à quand on parlait
détendre en auvergne maintenant tu
deviens cannois avec les menaces de
câbles voilà donc le tournoi de cannes
un grand classique le tournoi qui va se
dérouler au carlton donc dans un des
hôtels mythiques de la croisette
et là vous pourrez voir donc de très
près leurs joueurs se rencontrer dans le
monde dans un cadre luxueux très propre
auto alors il a été un petit peu avancé
maintenant il a lieu donc en juillet au
lieu du mois d'août au lieu de début
août
organisé par damien le match donc qui
est donc qu'on président club voilà mon
président de club donc il veut faire
donc un tournoi une sorte de tournoi des
stars puisque chaque année le champion
de france en titre et n 1 gros est
invité etienne bacrot sera donc là bas
donc si vous rêvez de rencontrer diane
bacrot si vous avez envie de bronze et
si vous avez envie de passer des
vacances sympathique et en même temps je
m'attendais le chèque le tournage en
effet pour vous à noter que tous les
tournois de l'été sont plus ou moins
fait pour vous donc cannois ya beaucoup
de tournants ya trois tournois
différents de tous niveaux et c'est
ensuite que nous arrivons qui commencent
le 12 août si je ne fais pas d'erreur
jean nuit qu'il s'agit de la compétition
française la plus prisée de l'année
c'est le championnat de france
vraiment la cadillac des tournants et
voilà donc le chocolat font ceux de
marseille voilà qui aura lieu au parc
chanot qui aura lieu donc dans un
un cadre magnifique et qui va durer donc
de deux semaines et ça va être le plus
fortement de l'année le plus beau
tournoi de l'année puisqu'il y aura
probablement mille participants c'est
incroyable dans une une telle présence
de joueurs sur une aussi courte période
alors là par contre ce tournoi ce
championnat de france on peux pas
vraiment vous en parler pour une raison
très simple et bien c'est que c'est dans
une ville différente tous les ans donc
l'année dernière c'était à vichy l'année
prochaine
cette année ça sera à marseille donc on
ne peut rien vous dire de plus mise à
part que c'est à marseille et que donc
il fera chaud sur le port de la
canebière tout simplement alors
aujourd'hui je vais profiter donc une
petite pause dans ces tournois de l'été
nous allons faire un moment championnat
de france tu vas participer au tournoi
donc il faut se préparer c'est un
tournoi qui se prépare on connaît déjà
le nom des joueurs c'est extrêmement
fort avec 2562 moyenne cette année donc
c'est vraiment considérable
c'est le plus fort championne de france
qui ait jamais eu toutes les stars
seront là bas donc ça c'est la fiche
c'est le tournoi national il y à 7
joueurs
ensuite on oui il ya plusieurs tournois
y à l'accession qui réservait aux
classements internationaux l'open à pour
les bons joueurs de clubs l'open b pour
les joueurs moins bon bref vous savez de
toute façon un tournoi pour vous mais ce
qui nous intéresse principalement celles
au national avec cette année donc joël
lautier etienne bacrot laurent
frayssinet envahi sokolov nocives
dorfman christian bauer anatolie weiser
ils sont tous là jean-marc degraeve
légalement est ce qu'un favori
donc je vais non peut-être question une
question importante
donc je pense qu'il ya un favori
pour ce tournoi je n'avais pas trop
envie de me prononcer sur cette question
puisque je participe à la compétition et
ses favorites sera un adversaire
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
difficile à avouer mais bon on va quand
même le dire un petit peu
personnellement je pense qu'il tienne
macro et est le favori mais bon c'est
quand même pas une surprise puisque
etienne bacrot à gagner le champion de
france l'année dernière et il y a deux
ans etienne bacrot donc champion sortant
ça va être extrêmement chaud donc on
sait que le national est organisé sur
une scène ya projections sur des écrans
géants commentaires par case infrarouge
donc si vous jouez le tournoi que vous
finissez votre parti assez rapidement
vous pouvez venir dans la salle du
national observé les parties donc de
tous est très fort grand maître
ça va être du beau spectacle donc
etienne bacrot favorise laurent
frayssinet laurent frayssinet outsider
très sérieux
probablement un des candidats les plus
sérieux donc pour le podium puisque
cette année il y là il a très très bien
joué
bon il se trouve que à montpellier c'est
pas le top mais je crois que
actuellement l'auront fait quelques
réglages pour le championnat de france
et après je peux être paris on en saura
plus sur le sur la forme de laurent
frayssinet derniers tournois de l'été
pour conclure c'est le tournoi de
saint-chély-d'aubrac qui commence le 26
août donc juste après le championnat de
france tournoi organisé par le très
sympathique jean claude - le président
du club de txingudi club de clichy donc
qui sera là bas pour vous accueillir
tournoi échec 20 pétanque et champignons
qui avait aussi organisé de la
cueillette de champignons pour tous ce
que ça peut intéresser donc
saint-chély-d'aubrac pour toutes les
infos vous allez sur le site ffe et
check point commun site de la fédération
française d'échecs géant lui tout de
suite
actualité internationale le tournoi de
donc le mémorial
vidmar qui a eu lieu donc je ne sais
plus dans quelle ville à milan à bidon
milan étant le prénom de vie demain donc
ne pas s'y tromper ça n'a pas aidé
habillant mais peu importe donc très
forte on a grand maître duquel est tiré
notre parti commenté
donc il y avait beaucoup de très fort
joueur notamment beddiaf qui gueulent
fonde caujolle qui sont des très forts
grand maître est la star montante des
échecs ukrainien donc on se rappelle du
match mais il faut que maintenant il ya
trente ans donc c'est plus vraiment une
star montante mais le petit nouveau donc
c'est volo kittin andrei volo keating
qui n'a que 14 ans et qu'il abat termine
troisième du temps va donc performance
exceptionnelle vélo kittin jeune je
crois que tu avais déjà eu l'occasion de
le voir quand tu a accompagné une
délégation française aux championnats de
aux championnats du lot chavaux
olympiades aux olympiades jeunes c'est
donc c'est par équipe de quatre des
jeunes qui ont moins de 16 ans voilà
donc j'avais accompagné donc l'équipe
française qui s'était très très bien
conduit puisque j'avais coach est aussi
et on en avait fait une neuvième et
volent au kit il donc été le leader de
l'équipe ukrainienne
c'est un jeune joueur un petit blondinet
de 14 ans et il avait été déjà très très
impressionnant
il faut savoir déjà qu'à cet âge là il
ya des joueurs qui ont un niveau de jeu
exceptionnel évolué kittin en fait
partie c'était donc le cas devolo kittin
et tout de suite nous allons sans plus
attendre vous commenter une partie du
jeune volo kittin où il bat un grand
maître expérimenté donc toujours très
fort grand maître qui doit être
bosniaque un oui donc que joule qui est
bosniaque
crois tu je ne sais plus et donc le
joueur qu joule donc qui qui est un
joueur très très très très expérimenté
et c'est amusant de voir enfin amusant
peut-être pas trop pour que je joue le
handicap c'est très intéressant de voir
comment un jeune enfant on peut peu
malmené donc un joueur aussi aguerri que
cela englobe un jeune enfant alors
attention il faut se méfier parce qu'on
se rappelle de beaucoup de jeunes
enfants notamment etienne bacrot à 14
ans il était tout petit toujours dit
tout mignon mais il était déjà un grand
maître international
volot kittin ne va pas tarder à l'être
il affiche déjà un hello un classement
elo de 2500 51 à 14 ans c'est vraiment
exceptionnel tant lui puisque je crois
que etienne où laurent frayssinet
n'avait pas un tel classement à 14 ans
oui c'est un classement incroyable et
les bons sa préparation justifie son
classement c'est un joueur était très
bien préparée et qui connaît déjà
énormément de choses sur le jeu d'échecs
tout de suite donc la partie volot
kittin cojoux l' échiquier et c'est
parti premier coup de quatre
les jeunes ont tendance à jouer aux
quatre jean-luc oui les jeunes donc
joue souvent leucate à l'exception des
tiennes qui lui au tout début à
commencer par le coucher de g3
curieusement donc etienne qui a mis
longtemps avant de jouer des deux des
cats qui jouait donc d ouverture un
petit peu comme tu le dirait un petit
peu rampante rampante un vol un style un
petit peu
original on va dire pour éviter les
lignes classiques éviter les grosses
préparations et surtout donc etienne qui
avait commencé par g3 pour apprendre
surtout le jeu de pièces le jeu dans le
milieu de jeu donc aux quatre c'est un
coût beaucoup plus direct effectivement
que des quatre c'est ça amène des
positions beaucoup plus déterminé très
vite beaucoup plus connu ces cinq la
cécilienne donc là évidemment qu aujourd
hui ne refuse pas le combat ils jouent
systématiquement ses 5 il connaît très
bien
cavalier f3 cas mais nécessite et là un
petit hors de combat alain cavalier 3 en
troisième où jean-luc voilà donc on ne
joue pas des quatre tout de suite ça
c'est la première remarque des cartes ça
sera une sicilienne ouverte
donc c'est le coup classique dans cette
position après psion prend des quatre on
reprend un cavalier et nous avons une
sicilienne ouverte en jouant qui avait
laissé 3 qu'est-ce qu'on évite et
qu'est-ce qu'on rend possible un voilà
donc un ordre de coups un peu
particulier qui évite certaines
sicilienne on peut supposer que que le
jeune voleur kittin n'a pas envie de
jouer peut-être une schennikov ou une
kalachnikov
alors on va expliquer ce que c'est ça
veut dire que si on joue des cadres dans
cette position tout de suite qui est
donc le coup le plus fréquemment joué
puis on prend des quatre qu'elle prend
des 4 ici les noirs peuvent jouer eux 7
5 7 5
c'est une kalachnikov voilà avec des
idées totalement curieuse mais ça existe
ou alors le coup cavani est lisse et
après calais c3 maintenant le coût de
cette 5e 5 et là c'est une flèche qui
peuvent voilà donc ces deux sicilienne
possible pour les noirs et en jouant au
troisième coup dans cette position non
pas des quatre meka et c3 d'abord avec
l'idée donc de jouer des quatre par la
suite
eh bien on évite ces lignes par exemple
si les noirs veulent jouer cavalier je
crois que c'est très dangereux tout de
suite c'est leur veulent jouer cavalier
6 les blancs sont à la disposition
disposition donc un cookie qui est à la
mode actuellement c'est le couffo f1 b
sainte ont flambé 5
voilà donc un coût qui est très très
jouée actuellement et qui fait partie d
grand débat théorique de de ce début de
xxième siècle puisque là on menace
éventuellement prononcer si ce cas ci la
structure d'options ensuite avancé e45
beaucoup de possibilités pour les blancs
donc ici c'est pas évident après le
bouquet et c3 de jouer cabinet cite donc
normalement on joue soit des six soit au
6 mai à ce moment là effectivement
l'aspect chlykov et la kalachnikov ne
sont plus possibles
en tout cas les systèmes que doit jouer
coujoux sont probablement évité et c'est
pour ça que je joue le sort donc des et
évite donc le
le débat empêche les blancs d'ouvrir la
position au centre en jour le coût de
cet os 5 qui évidemment est radicale
c'est le principal inconvénient de jouer
qui a laissé 3 c'est qu'on n'a pas joué
des 4 et donc les noirs peuvent jouer
aux cinq empêchant effectivement
radicalement d'avancé central des blancs
des deux des cadres c'est le principal
donc avantage de secouer 7 5 mais qui a
malheureusement beaucoup d'inconvénients
et il faut rappeler que récemment garry
kasparov a battu piquette dans cette
ligne avec les blancs et et que tous les
joueurs de top niveau avec les blondes
un très bon résultat dans cette ligne
effectivement le problème positionnelle
d'avoir deux pions comme ça en a eu cinq
essais 5 c'est que la casse des cinq ne
pourra plus jamais être protégé par un
pion puisse corruption ils reviennent
pas en arrière jean luc donc les blancs
peuvent s'installer sur cette case et
les noms n'ont pas de moyens de les
chasser
oui tout à fait et en plus donc là après
le couffo sekkat très naturel on profite
donc de ce trou en d5 et en même temps
de l'attak du pian f7 donc les petits
inconvénients tactique qui se pose un
petit peu sur le roi noir
maintenant les noirs doivent doivent
terminer leur développement le plus le
plus classiquement donc des 6 un coût
que de toute façon on aurait été amené à
jouer donc pourquoi ne pas jouer tout de
suite des trois normales tout à fait
classique donc là par exemple sur un
coup comme cavani m6 il ya une réponse
positionnelle jean-luc 1 dans ce genre
dans ce type de position
quelle ineptie donc coûts qui contrôle
la 4 des 5 on peut régulièrement jouer
des coups comme tous les cinq
alors là je me suis trompé c'est fou
j'ai 5 avec l'idée d'échangé de
rencontre le cavalier est ensuite
d'installer un cavalier en d5 qui sera
donc un chat sable mais je crois que
même cavalier assiste dans cette
position et est interdite
peut-être à cause du coût cavaliers
cavaliers j'ai 5 kg 5 encore plus fort
pour forcer pour ça que dans cette
position les noirs commencent par le ou
full 7 puisque là on voit que le
cavalier attaque le pion à vii et le fou
aussi le pion qui donc va être perdu oui
tout à fait ici donc c'est très clair on
ne peut pas chaque année 1,6 on joue
donc forcément on commence par flo le
set
donc petit rock et petit rock donc petit
rock curieusement qui est une
parce qu'une nouveauté qui est une qui
est par presque une nouveauté qui est un
des courts et sans qu'ils aient joué
dans cette position ce que je rencontre
jouée h quatre jeunes en ont commencé
dans cette position par un camélidé deux
cas validé deux ont commencé par ce coup
très curieux alors on va expliquer un
petit peu cavalier d2 et les landes par
kasparov entre autres pourquoi est-ce
qu'on va l'expliquer parce que c'est un
coût qui n'est pas naturel pour la bonne
raison qu'on joue deux fois et quand
même chose dans l'ouverture et que ça
évidemment c'est quelque chose que vous
devez absolument éviter si vous n'êtes
pas sûr de ce que vous faites donc cette
position est très simple cavaliers des
deux est transféré vers la case f1 puis
la case e3 et se dirige vers cette
fameuse case centrale des 5
donc on va probablement installé l'autre
cavaliers en d5 lecavalier c3 et après
donc on pourra jouer ses trois contrôles
et la case des cats et développer ses
pièces tant qu'ils vont en faire petit
road et f4 donc total contrôle de la
caisse des 5 voilà normalement ça
commence par le coup cavaliers f3 en d2
on ne vote pas pour ne pas mettre la
tour sur la case a faim on laisse cette
case livres ont fait la manipulation et
à créon rock et ensuite on repasse que
si on explique un petit peu on explique
aux téléspectateurs ce qui se passe si
on fait petit rock d'abord et qu'on veut
jouer ce plan et caves et les d2 on voit
qu'il ya une tour en f1 et
malheureusement on doit bouger cette
tour en est un que si on a fait peu tir
haut qui fait une plage des cavaliers en
f1 pour venir e3 et remettre la tour en
f1 puisque on veut jouer f4 white donc
on perdre de temps effectivement c'est
pour ça qu'on commence par cavaillé deux
cavaliers f1 subtilité mais si petit
robe choisie par bolo kittin donc un
coût qui développe encore une pièce on
voit que les blancs sorti quatre pièces
donc le roi de cavaliers un fou les
doigts on n'en sortit que 2 et problème
ici sur camélia science je crois
jean-luc
que se passe-t-il alors cavalière 6 kg
et le coup classique dans sa position
oui mais il est possible que que je ne
sois pas très bien préparé dans cette
ligne là parce que bon la ligne gênante
ses cavaliers g5 le coût direct
cavaliers g5 petit rock pour défendre le
pion à vii donc le roi qui défend à vii
et la tour qui défend un set
il fallait quand même constater que
calais g5 et le fou ces quatre attaques
et le point f7 deux fois également
et après donc petit rôle maintenant les
blancs lance l'initiative par eve de f4
donc là ils vont ouvrir en plus la
colonne pour la toile f1 donc ça va
faire une tour qui travaillent un
cavalier qui travaillent et un fou qui
travaillent dans tout ça sur le cloud of
les blancs ont du jeu dans cette
position les blancs ont du jeu mais je
pense que la position de la et quand
même
et quand même à peu près équilibré quand
même acceptable à va dire que c'est la
ligne principale tout simplement
c'est là l'une principale est là dans
cette position que joule donc à jouer le
coup fut si ce qui existe aussi il faut
pas minimiser l'efficacité de ce coup
donc évidemment si et blanc prénom au 6
et noir reprennent avec le pion et
qu'est ce qu'on voit et bien ceux qui
ont aussi si le contrôle très bien les
cases blanches centrale donc en fait
c'est des pions doublé certes mais
efficace
oui évidemment de ramener un pur vers le
centre n'est pas une mauvaise chose pour
les noirs puisqu'on peut aussi d'ouvrir
les colonnes f après la reprise ouvre la
colonne f
ce qui leur permettra un peu plus tard
après le petit rock de faire jouer leur
pièce directement tout en contrôlant
très très bien le centre puisque le plan
réussisse contrôler la gaze des cinq la
case des cats et très bien contrôlé les
noirs sont mûres au centre tout à fait
donc on ne prend pas en russie ce après
ce coup on joue qu'à valider cinq c'est
très logique donc validé cinq on
continue donc cette idée d'occuper donc
7 4 centrales le cap est l'un des cinq à
un superbe avant-postes et la seule
solution actuellement ce serait
d'éliminer donc 2
le fou aux 6 pour se débarrasser du
cavaly ce qui est actuellement
inconcevable puisque ce serait donner
donc ce qu'on appelle la paire de fou et
en plus se retrouver avec un font
recette qui fait grise mine tout à fait
d'autant plus que les noirs n'aurait
plus aucune protection sur les cases
blanches une fois qu'ils ont donnés leur
fameux [ __ ] cases blanches qui est
quand même un des ultimes protecteur de
tout cet ensemble de cases
il faut donc jouer cavalier m6 le
fighting pour les thèses des cinq qui
commence c'est normal del un cavalier
apsys oui un coût de développement
classique et là qu'avait dit g5 donc eu
l'idée
l'idée très agressif du jeune du jeune
volo kittin donc toujours augmenter donc
cette pression sur cette diagonale à 2 à
2 g 8 puisque le cavalier attaque lui la
case e6 et la case f7 et que les noirs
dans cette position ne pourront pas
garder leur flou sur cette diagonale
c'est pour ça que les noirs ont décidé
d'abandonner ce fou
la menace directe jean-luc s'est donc
calé profond aux six cavaliers pro nazi
est fou prend le site est fou c'est
apprendre aussi ce qui sera pas défendue
donc réaction tout à fait normal fou
prend des cinq donc foutront dessin qui
est moins grave que tout à l'heure
puisque dans cette position les blancs
ne vont pas reprendre avec le fou ce
serait se sentent qu'ils avaient des
preuves liées au sein qui perdrait un
pion exactement dont ils vont reprendre
avec le pion et on ferme la diagonale à
2 g 8 ce qui est un petit inconvénient
pour eux où ils ont poussé quatre
centres on retrouve bien moins efficace
parce qu'il est bloqué est un pion des
cinq que lorsqu'il avait tout la
diagonale pour lui tout seul mais les
blancs garde malgré tout
de nombreux avantages que l'on va
découvrir dans quelques instants alors
jean-luc une petite remarque tout de
suite il ya une pseudo combinaisons
qu'on pourrait avoir envie de jouer
c'est le coup cavaliers prend des 5 1
oui donc cavalier prendre 5 qui une
pseudo combinaisons on pourrait penser
que c'est à peu près la même chose
c'est-à-dire sur fion cavaliers fou
projet sagd on gagne un pion oui tout à
fait il semblerait que les noirs et
récupérer leurs billes et oui et c'est à
dire d'un match 5
j'ai l'impression exactement de la
malchance ils menacent mat
d'un côté et menace de gagner le fou
gestion de l'autre côté
donc c'est une attaque double qui est
tout simplement imparables et ici
évidemment puisqu'on ne peut pas je me
fous français intermédiaire puisque amat
donc au coup d'après les blancs vont
gagner de fou g5 donc tout simplement ça
ne marche pas qu'elle prend des 5
oui ça ne marche pas du tout il faut
donc après je prends des cinq bouger le
calice et 6 qui se retrouvent méchamment
emprise et le ramener sur la caisse
bébittes et c'est là que volo kittin
innove puisqu'on est encore en terrain
connu et joue le coup 10 f 4
précédemment ont préféré jouer fou des
cinq échecs suis vite ces deux c4 un bon
c'était peut-être un peu curieux mais en
tout cas c'est ce qu'ont joué avant
alors que la r4 a l'air beaucoup plus
naturelle jean-luc beaucoup plus violent
un chat donc finalement une nouveauté
qui n'a rien d'exceptionnel en elle-même
puisque c'est le coup naturel dans cette
position c'est à dire que les blancs
sont mieux développer les blancs les
blancs en rock et alors que là on vient
de voir les noirs repli leurs cavaliers
sur sa case initiale akasbi mythe
donc pourquoi ne pas ouvrir la position
pour faire jouer leur pièce au maximum
c'est quand même très logique
tout simplement il faut se poser la
question quand on arrive à une position
comme celle qu'on a là comment faire
pour valoriser mon avantage de
développement est bien pour cela jean
luc il faut faire tout péter
tout simplement exactement donc f4 le
coup le coup tout le monde attends tu en
prends acte et voilà la menace est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'avant se positionnait
l'été f5
je suis pas sûr justement c'est pour ça
il ya aussi la menace tactique f 35 puis
on prend 1,5 et après il ya des
possibilités de
d'ouvrir la position par des cinq des
six de nombreuses combinaisons
surgissent à cet instant de la partie
lui tout à fait donc ici bon piont
princes 4 c'est un coup pas c'est
naturel c'est le coût normal donc pu en
prendre quatre et après vingt-quatre fou
pour être quatre voilà les pièces
blanches sont quasiment toutes
développées alors que les noirs
non non rien développé il va y avoir un
embouteillage côté noir mais une
remarque importante jean-luc le fou c4
est quand même mal placé puisqu'il est
emmurée par ses propres pions donc sur
le long terme
supposons que les noirs arrivent à
échanger des pièces par exemple une
paire de cavaliers et des fous de cases
noires mais un long run pratiquement
gagné la partie
et oui mais pour positionner les terres
d'un point du positionnelle mais le jeu
dynamique va vraiment changer
enfin tout changer vraiment changé les
données de la position faut quand même
voir aussi que dans cette position le
fou en deux sets
on n'est vraiment pas un très bon fou il
est il et cela reste un mauvais fond il
n'a qu'une seule case la case f8 encore
une fois de la case initiale
et sinon il est bien bien enfermés
derrière ce cas là il faut
impérativement que les noirs se
réorganise qui bougent leurs cavaliers
qu'ils arrivent à sortir le fouet cette
sur la case et 6 peut être revenir
contrôler la case au 5 mai tout ça c'est
pas si facile d'autant plus que pour
l'instant il ya toujours par ok au joli
nom qu'elle joue petit rock et c'est là
que ça commence à chauffer c'est là que
ça commence à chauffer donc dames deux
dameuses donc la pression monte le jeune
mollo kittin qui décide de placer ses
pièces tranquillement sur la colonne eux
on va le montre la bd dont deux dames au
dos excellent il est tout de toute façon
il faut ramener toujours du sang neuf à
la tac ça c'est clair
donc dans cette position très
naturellement on envie de faire jouer la
torah inquiets pièces qui ne joue pas
pour l'instant d'autres jouent dames 2
l'idée donc effectivement lié les tours
sans étude jouait tout revin c'en est
une autre qui va attaquer fou aux sept
premières remarques qui avait attaqué la
foule s'était finalement complètement
désorganisée
donc les noirs cavaliers d'aidé s'ajoute
à la libé 17
peut-on vraiment reprocher un tel coup
non non tout ravin normale et l'a donc
triste nécessité donc la tour f 8 qui
défend le fond de cette tombe on le fout
menace peut être de revenir donc sur la
case et fuite et à partir de ce moment
là les noirs pourraient se réorganiser
s'ils recommencent à déjà par échanger
des pièces sur la colonne eux puisque
quand il ya une colonne ouverte
il faut rappeler que les toutes les
pièces lourdes ont tendance à s'échanger
dessus jean luc ça c'est très important
donc si on échange toutes les pièces ne
sommes ensuite on a déjà énormément
alléger la tension est plus qu'alléchant
j'ai encore d'autres pièces et
finalement les blancs resterait en fin
de compte avec leur fils et câbles qu'il
est pas mal
donc ça c'est le projet très nette des
noirs donc dans cette position que joue
la très bien puisque je suis bien j'ai
plus qu'à prendre mon temps et changer
quelques trucs et je vais le faire le
petit jeune
et oui mais malheureusement là le petit
jeune donc ce fait le vieux a trouvé il
a trouvé il a trouvé l'armé fatale dans
cette position
c'est un the making attaque exactement
il a trouvé quelque chose de génial un
truc quand les premières l'inattendu
alors c'est reparti toptent actes
identiques tactique donc regarder cette
position toutes les pièces blanches sont
à fond vous avez 5 secondes pour trouver
le coup de massue le coup de tonnerre
dans un ciel serein comme on l'appelle 5
4 4 3 2 1
cavaye preuve sept cavaliers price
adhérer aux cavaliers premier set voilà
la petite combinaison de l'été sacrifice
de pièces quand même bon alors ce qu'il
faut voir et prendre cette attaque la
dame
les noirs sont obligés de jouer rampant
cavaliers sinon ils sont ridicules
oui sinon le cavalier nous en perdons en
plus exactement maintenant audard celui
d'amos six échecs
le roi doit venir sur la case f8 alors
sinon il ya maintenant 5
c'est mathématique sur roger 6 nous vous
montrons ici il faut ramener du sang
neuf avec le coût des quatre et le four
revient sur la casse dès le retour de
fond des trois est totalement fatale
puisque qu'en droit bien sûr la case
achat
la dame se ramène sur la cage trois
essais matt donc ici matt fort c'est
donc après damas six échecs roi et
fuites et là jean luc
qu'est ce qui s'passe ya pas de maths
non il n'y a pas de match mais on voit
que les lignes en face du roi sont
ouvertes
donc la tour f 1 qui est juste en face
du roi n'a plus qu'une seule pièce
adverse qui est qui la gêne c'est le
cavalier m6 alors attention jean-luc
parce que ce cavalli est très très
sévèrement protéger on voit quatre
pièces noires qui le protège quand même
nous qui va falloir de faire des efforts
pour le virer il va falloir faire des
efforts donc un petit effort
d'imagination dans cette position quelle
est la pièce qui peut aller chatouiller
ce cas vaillant m6 c'est simple série
d'options c'est le pion alors donc le
pion qui menace très sérieusement
d'avancé on va en voir voir un petit peu
les avantages il ya aussi là dedans que
la tour e 1 et la dame six qui sont en
batterie sur la colonne e et la paire de
fou qui ne demande finalement qu'à jouer
à n'importe quel moment je pense que le
plus important dans cette position
jean-luc ce qu'il faut ce qui a permis à
vau-l'eau kittin de trouver cette
combinaison qui finalement se retrouvent
gagnante c'est que les noirs n'ont pas
de moyen de sortir d'un embouteillage de
pièces totalement effrayant
embouteillages qui est surtout lié
finalement à la très très mauvaise
position de ce four en deux sets
on ne s'arrêtait pas là et ont préféré
ne pas voir sa troupe du tout puisque le
four 7 ne peut pas bouger du tout le roi
en fuite c'est physique
ils peuvent pas bouger c'est une
paralysie totale et les blancs profite
immédiatement de cette paralysie en
jouant le coup
qu'on a mentionné le coup j'ai du g24 on
y va on va jouer chez cinq et on va
chatouiller le cas des abscisses ça
c'est clair
le gros problème des noirs dans cette
position jean luc c'est que le cou
cavalier e 5 n'est pas possible ça c'est
ça qui est ennuyeux
enfin disons qu'il ya 500 seul coup mais
surtout prend 1,5 j'en prends plein ils
viennent le coût des cinq des six des
cinq des six suivi d'un math imparable
avec la batterie d'un fou sur la case
afssaps sur l'a47 et aussi sur la casse
g8 et aussi sur la case ie8 c'est
important puisque le caveau vieillissent
et cloud et voilà doit faire de jolis
matt donc deux matchs possibles donc
c'est tout le problème dans cette
position on ne peut pas jouer cavalier
seul puisque le faut bien prendre
et quand le pion reprend est bien ou pas
libération du killer en c4 c'est pour ça
que coujoux décide de tenter quelque
chose pour se débarrasser de ce fou c4
mais évidemment c'est beaucoup trop long
ils jouent le coup à 6 à 6 il ne sait
vraiment plus quoi faire donc ça ah si
c'est un coût qui peut être interprété
comme une capitulation pure et simple
dans cette position que joue le heavy et
bien j'attends de voir comment tu vas me
matter mais j'ai aucun doute là dessus
je sais que mon compte est bon oui
effectivement et là le jeune volgin a
trouvé une méthode très très élégante
pour terminer cette partie il joue le
coup j'ai 5
oui une suite logique de ce qu'ils
avaient préparées auparavant des cinq
des 5 c'est normal à voter quand même
pour les spécialistes qui regardent que
la seule défense c'était le coup cabello
5 jean-luc dans cette position qui a dit
aux cinq qui étaient pas
pas si difficile pas si facile que ça
puisque après fou pour un f6 là le coup
très curieusement c'est le ku'damm c'est
vital donc ça paraît très curieux mais
c'est la seule variante qui non c'est
même pas ça d'ailleurs puisque là en
fait on y arrive pas du tout à tenir
non toutes les semaines il y avait en
projet 6 par exemple les exemples ne
manquent pas donc en fait dans cette
position je sais qu'à une défense mais
elle est vraiment fumeuses et arrive
dans une finale tout à fait difficile et
programmes en perdante
donc là tout simplement que joue le
temps de l'es5 et là surprise le petit
boulot kittin puisqu'il est vraiment
petit nez est jeune et donc on s'attend
vent ou pas si soit si fort ne prend pas
de signal et oui le jeune mollo kittin
un petit peu dans la lignée donc de
kasparov quand il était jeune aussi
décide finalement dans cette position de
jouer la thématique donc la thématique
de la position verrouillé l'adversaire
ne peut pas développer ces pièces eh
bien on va lui faire un plan
abracadabrant sur quelques coups mais on
va les mater tout à fait donc on va lui
jouer tours 2-3 c'est dire qu'en fait
les noirs ne peuvent toujours rien faire
c'est ça qui est affreux la menace
jean-luc tour trois tours h trois mois
je crois et rejette par exemple pour
preuve cette décision j'ai six dans
cette position que j'ai 6 ou g6 et
masque le bâton à vii et si le pion et
s'illustrant la tour vient à schwyz et
aux matons coup suivant tout à fait donc
ici c'est un plan non encore une fois
l'idée cet ouvrage 3 mais pratiquement
parable donc c'est ici qu'est la défense
en fait jean luc qui était donc tu
reprends ces cas dans cette position au
choix les blancs jouent à peu près ce
qu'ils veulent donc par exemple tour h3
une tour atx 3 wii et maintenant
cavalier 5 m voilà donc qui avait lieu 5
qui qui cette fois fonctionne puisque
après faut prendre ça qu'on peut jouer
d'abc voilà exactement l'idée c'est de
jouer dame s'est vite il faut absolument
et impérativement échanger les dames
dans cette position donc ça c'est encore
une règle d'or jean-luc quand on est
attaqué très méchamment
il faut échanger des pièces qui
attaquent notamment les dames parce que
c'est des pièces qui font très mal
et oui mesdames s'entraîner mais que je
joue donc qu'ils n'avaient pas envie de
d'échanger les dames donc jouer qui est
très fidèles à saddam et les raisons
cela dit notre ami donc croate
voilà notre avis 3 qui est donc conservé
sa damongeot javel du casio 5 mais
malheureusement à force de conserver sa
dame mais il a fini par perdre le roi
d'arabie c'est le sait le problème c'est
le grand dilemme de cette fin de
puisque ce recueil de ce parti il ya eu
fou prend 1,5 il faut prendre 5 qui
menacent donc si on prend cavalli avec
multiples pièces de plus donc surtout on
prend 1,5
il ya un lien immédiat et c'est ce que
nous montre volo kittin puisque c'est la
partie j'existe up tactique mais
jean-luc donc tu as cassé les faits
c'est g6 le coup tactique ces menaces
dérive sept matches et là c'était tout à
l'heure ici la seule défense donc là ici
il ya eu abandon de cojoux puisque sur
pied un projet si ce qui est la seule
défense contre le mat et bien là il ya
plusieurs coups qui gagne notamment tout
vaches trois tours h3 suivi de tous âges
suite suivi de tours à schwyz
imparable échec et mat puisque le
cabinet oc c pourrait de toute façon il
ya plus de défense d'accorder plus il
n'ya plus donc on va revoir ce qui s'est
passé c'était comme ça tout ravin enfin
d'abord d'aveux 2 qui coûte qui n'a
l'air de rien qui avait 17 tours à 20
tours lui et auront huit les noirs sont
tout à fait serein et on se dira
j'échange toutes les pièces sur la
colonne ouvertes et ensuite je vais
jouer ma meilleur sauteur de pions les
meilleures pièces mais la boum bimbo
même biboum qu'avec un visa n'accepte
roi prend damas six échecs donc on a
donné une pièce croix et fuite et
embouteillages embouteillages donc
personne ne bouge plus personne ne bouge
donc les blancs ont la main totalement
libres ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent ils jouent g4 manager 5
mais il n'y a pas de défense donc à six
tentatives désespérées g5 b5 et
maintenant tour 3 encore du sang neuf la
tour ne faisait pas un travail suffisant
il faut l'améliorer la perfectionner la
tour qui valait trois milliards
donc on l'a fait passer sur la troisième
rangée cavaliers aux 5 fu prendre 5
surprend un sac et j'ai six à dix la
petite finale toc ce qui fait que dans
cette pression volo kittin s'est imposé
donc très belle victoire du jeune
très belle victoire une victoire très
caractéristique chez ce genre de jeunes
joueurs donc il envoie le bois c'est
vrai que le problème c'est quand en
général quand on perd contre 1 contre un
très jeune joueur ou calcul très très
bien et il est capable de punir donc
c'est un petit peu une punition de
perdre une partie comme ça c'est pas une
partie avec une finale avec avec un
match à long terme c'est très brutal et
c'est vraiment très simple c'est un cas
où se joue le ko debout nous allons tout
de suite enchaîné maintenant aujourd'hui
qui avec des joueurs d'expérience avec
le niveau de la classe mondiale puisque
aujourd'hui commencer le célèbre tournoi
de dortmund
donc si vous voulez voir des images sur
ce superbe sparkassen meeting allemand
et bien vous allez sur les émissions
diagonale de l'année passée vous avez
donc des images du tournoi quelques
interviews des joueurs et cette année
jean luc plateau exceptionnel puisqu'il
y a les deux champions du monde donc
vladimir kramnik et mi-chemin à tana
nombre et il ya également peter lee
comme alcool adams alexander morozevich
et vaseline topalov et vesselin topalov
donc un très beau plateau six joueurs
double ronde tout de suite donc jean luc
quel est ton favori qui est le meilleur
joueur de ce tournoi est ce que c'est un
manque d'eau chronique puisque c'est de
toute évidence mais de plus fort bond
je crois que pour ce tour assez probable
que cram dit qu'elle soit le grand
favori puisque
puisqu'il a il a quand même une revanche
à prendre
il a perdu il ya quelques il ya quelques
semaines contrat non d'un petit point on
départage un match exhibition mais il
avait déjà terminé deuxième du tournoi
d'astana donc l'admirent chronique qui
avait été en tête tout le tournoi s'est
fait doubler par kasparov donc il est
énervé il est remonté la lumière
thermique alors que la non lui allait
gagner tranquillement au mexique à
mérida donc ici
travnik qui en veut qui ça fait
longtemps qu'il n'a pas gagné de tournoi
vladimir kramnik il est donc surmotivés
et tout de suite un segment de parti qui
vient d'être joué pas plus tard que tout
à l'heure la partie vestine topalov
vladimir kramnik on va vous je suis
souvent montré un morceau puisqu'il ne
reste pas beaucoup de temps
juste pour montrer la technique
monstrueuse de vladimir kramnik donc
quand on parle de technique monstrueuse
jean-luc qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand on voit comment joue crowded donc
les positions aussi ça
c'est sa grande force et ses capacités
donc finalement à croître à augmenter un
avantage minime minuscule et d'obtenir
une victoire très très simplement au
jour des coups magnifiques surtout
contre un joueur de la classe de
wesseling topalov il a donc 2711 c'est
le meilleur joueur bulgare depuis des
années il est invité dans tous les
grands tournois
les sprinters palop donc il est très
expérimenté là vous avez devant vous
cette position cavaye j'ai un sétois
noir de jouer au premier rang jean-luc
les devants en plus des espaces
c'est vrai bon mais leurs voix et
légèrement affaibli puisque les pions
sont avancées ce qui n'est pas grave
puisqu'on est dans une phase finale
quasi finale donc comme c'est une quasi
final il ne reste finalement plus qu'à
échanger quelques pièces et donc pour
save l'admirent chronique va le faire
très bien il ya une colonne ouverte ce
qui va donc lui permettre d'échanger
toutes les pièces lourdes et c'est la
première étape de son plan mais alors
qu'est-ce que c'est son plan comment est
ce qu'on peut dire dans cette finale qui
adore et donc égalité matérielle les
blancs pas plus de faiblesse que les
noirs pour l'instant c'est les blancs
qui ont la colonne ouverte
qu'est ce qui peut faire croire que un
jour gris mercredi contre un joueur
extrêmement fort va réussir à
transformer une position qui a l'air
aussi élémentaire est aussi égal d'un
point de vue purement technique on peut
quand même trouvé un petit avantage
un petit avantage dozos fille canon un
petit davantage de structures dans cette
position au noir bon allez droit c'est à
peu près égales et on va on va dire que
les pions sont aussi faibles les uns que
les autres
mehal elle allait à la dame il est
acheté il y a un petit pion en a trois
ça n'a pas l'air d'un grand chose mais
et c'est en fait il ya des pions à 2b 2c
4 contres à cette dé 6,6 5,1 ça n'a pas
grand chose dans cet art très peu mais
quand on est un spécialiste des finales
quand on a l'habitude de jouer ce genre
de position on se rend compte que la
structure blanche est moins bonne que la
structure noir et je crois qu'elle soit
tu va très très bien nous expliquer cet
avantage oui sans aucun doute
alors donc disons que les blancs ont
préféré avoir les qu on a deux des trois
essais 4 voilà d'accord mais ça
n'explique pas vraiment pourquoi est ce
que c'est si fade mais c'est justement
ce qu'on va voir tout de suite grâce à
vladimir kramnik et grâce donc à toi
jean luc puisque tu vas nous expliquer
ça avec brio et ben ce qui est simple
c'est que c'est si faible parce qu'une
chaîne de pions doit être unie aux
échecs et là on voit que pour défendre
le pion sekkat il va falloir pousser le
pion en b3 mais ce plan b 3 ne sera pas
soutenue d'accord ce sera déjà pas
protégés voilà et le pion à 3 également
ne sera pas soutenu d'accord donc ça
c'est des problèmes mais tout de suite
place à la technique qui voit là puisque
il nous avons connu une vingtaine de
coups a commenté il faut y aller retour
des 8es change donc des pièces sur la
colonne verte ça c'est la première étape
l'admirent chronique veut transposer au
final de cavaliers voilà d'où il fallait
aussi éliminer les seules pièces qui
joue de son adversaire donc la tour sur
la colline verte c'est une pièce à
éliminer tour contours dame prend d'amd
cette proposition d' échange massif
mêmes idées échangées la dame qui lui
qui activent dire que personne ne peut
tolérer que son adversaire possède la
colonne garde donc ils mènent à tous
leurs pièces dessus et les pièces
s'échange ça et c'est la finale de
cavaliers donc là on voit le cavalier de
blé d'hiver tram qui veulent bien sûr la
case au sein qui menèrent éminents et
qui menacent de s'installer sur la case
au sein de son pourra pas l'éviter b3
pour une fin de ces cartes
topalov qui défend ses 4es et maintenant
donc krainik qui essayait de se diriger
petit à petit vers le plan b 3 vers le
purgatoire donc là on peut déjà
envisager le plan qui a aidé trois cas
lycéens voilà l'une des premières idées
pour aller attaquer ce pion b3 il ya
effectivement d'autres possibilités mais
ce qui est très important final jean luc
c'est de monter le roi au centre ça on
va voir que kramnik le fait très bien
qu'elle et ses trois rois et 7 le mois
est une pièce forte il faut la même
centre il le fait très bien d'autant
plus que son roi à la facilité de monter
au centre puisqu'il a de l'espace plus
d'état c'est à dire que le roi blanc ne
peut pas monter sur la colonne f
et il aimerait bien mais il peut pas
puisque le pion aux quatre contrôles oui
c'est pour ça que topalov a décidé de
troquer 2
cas c'est un petit peu la structure a
les droits pour essayer de faire monter
son roi qui n'a que la possibilité de
descendre actuelle on peut supposer
qu'il était quand même préférable de
joueurs au f-22 savez peut-être la plus
logique
bien que ça devait poser d'autres
problèmes problème c'est qu'après trois
et vingt cavaliers detroit et sur deux
cavaliers c'est un échec qui
il ya des problèmes donc en fait cette
finale est pas facile puisqu'elle plombé
topalov joue le coup g4 qui apparemment
péremption en fait n'en perd pas
puisqu'une fois que le plus bref 5 n'est
plus là on l'a récupéré dans le cadre
mais ça pose un problème puisque trawick
projet 4h plongée kaki comprends j'ai
quatre cavaliers prend qu'elle les prend
1,4 et ici jean luc hess convois qui ont
passé éloignés et oui le fameux pions
pas s'éloigner
donc le pion h qui est un pur pas
s'éloigner alors comme on l'a expliqué
l'avantagent du pian passé éloigné c'est
que tous les bandes c'est qu'il est loin
c'est qu'il est loin il est loin de la
plupart des pions c'est à dire que après
un échange massif mais on y arrive de
toute façon on ya pouvoir l'expliquer
deux ans vers la plus rationnelle
pourquoi est ce que c'est important
d'avoir un pion passé éloignés et non
pas centrale donc s'éloigner par
opposition à un central tout simplement
à cause de ce qui suivra aussi ce qu'a
laissé trois cavaliers aux cinq retours
l'idée c'est de jouer g4 et qu'à venir
trois ans afin de fixer ce pion à deux
donc encore gagner de l'espace topology
f4 tiens prends tu comprends qu'elle ait
c6 et la pause jean-luc nous allons
expliquer maintenant pourquoi est-ce que
l'option h6 est bien plus fort que le f4
et c'est ça qui fait toute la différence
dans cette pétition bon ah ça il faut
ajouter effectivement ce que tu as dit
la fin de la crise à 6 quand il vient
des quatre vigiles attaquent b3 et oui
donc dans cette position c'est le
matériel est égal mais c'est
techniquement complètement perdu c'est
ça qui est incroyable et qu'il faut
expliquer ça c'est incroyable
donc le pur eux donc le pion passé
éloignait le pion h va s'échanger contre
le pion f
mais pour prendre ce pion h le roi blanc
va devoir aller sur la colonne h donc
très loin de l'action était loin d'être
très très loin l'action alors que le roi
noir lui va prendre le bus en bref tout
simplement est ce qui fait que pour la
course sera près de l'action lui pour la
course vers les pions à manger de
l'autre elle le roi noir sera le plus
rapide
donc qu'est ce qu'on voit dans cette
position tout de suite on voit que le
cas les c6 des fonctions à 7 qui défend
avec son v6 qui défendent france et 5
et comme le cas et c'est 6
les blancs ne peut pas l'attaquer et
bien déjà directement travnik à gauche
il est tranquille maintenant il va mener
son roi sur la tf 101 qui va provoquer
cet échange et quand son roi va se
ramener de ce côté là eh bien ça va être
razia dans les viandes blanches
d'autant plus que le pion b3 et le
maillon faible de la position blanche
le fameux maillon faible c'est le
maillon faible puisque il n'est pas
défendu s'annonce éliminé exactement il
faut l'éliminer donc c'est ce qui sera
fait dans quelques courtes camélidés
cinq tentatives de topalov h5 roger 3
très logique est ici peut-être un geste
technique de vladimir kramnik à 5 pour
empêcher les échanges de pions puisque
il pouvait probablement envisager de
descartes c'est à dire que sur wave 5
dans cette position jean luc nous allons
y revenir tout de suite sur le coup donc
croître cinq qui étaient possibles
cavaliers des six échecs ou b4
d'ailleurs ou des cats dans cette
position où peut-être bkb 4 puisque sur
a6 qui était la réponse probable qu ib 4
pour ensuite ramasser tubes et 400
clôture à 7 son emprise et bien il y
accueille des six échecs suivi de calais
s'est vite on attaque l'option b 6 et on
provoque des échanges de pions et sa
chronique ne veut pas puisque ses pions
ils sont pour lui c'est promis à son roi
qui va être plus actif que l'autre que
notre roi donc à 5
il ferme le contrôle des blancs sbk
quand on peut plus jouer b4 du tout donc
on joue un coup comme qui essaient cet
échec pour les attaquer le tueur bêtise
3 f 5 qui est des cinq caves elles
étaient quatre chacun son tour
pourquoi h4 donc là de toute façon c'est
pareil qu'elle prend b3 et là on voit
que le cabinet de chroniques et magique
puisqu'il défend et le pion à 5 et le
pian c5 donc topalov aura beau prendre
l'option décide c'est bien le roi de
crown vic va prendre en f4 c'est sûr
enfin il a joué des deux zones clés des
deux pour provoquer cavaliers pro b 6
qui est pro b si ce qu'ils lâchent la
défense 10.43 prend un f4 cavaliers à 4
et le retour du cavalière eux quatre ils
pouvaient aussi aller en b3 de toute
façon tous gagné puisque maintenant le
roi noir
ils arrivent déjà prendre ces quatre et
il va prendre à trois et les d'options
passé vont tout simplement se
transformer en dames où on allait faire
promotion et la partie est gagnée
d'autant plus que le cavalier ans à 4
doit mettre énormément de temps pour
prendre le seul pion qu'il peut prendre
le pion à 5
il faudrait qu'ils passent par la case
b6 17 b 8 essais 6 pour la provoquer à 5
à 4 tout simples robes qu'elle pousse
ses pions qui serait donc dépenses a dit
sur les blancs n'ont absolument aucun
contre jeu et c'est la transformation
donc on revoit la position initiale
c'est celle là après tg1 position qui
al'air égal mais qui en fait ne l'est
pas du tout alors jean-luc comme tu l'as
dit à gauche les pions blancs sont moins
forts que les pions noirs puisque le
tueur noir sont dans notre structure
parfaite donc ça c'est un détail
avantages auxquels s'ajoutent les
avantages des espaces pour les noirs qui
donc ici ils sont en plus avancé ce qui
leur permet de créer un pion pas
s'éloigner et ensuite de transformer
puisque les pions blancs sont faibles de
l'autre côté
donc c'est vraiment extrêmement
technique c'est une très très belle
leçon de finale que vladimir kramnik a
donné à topaloff est donc il prend la
tête du tournoi et critères légaux qui a
battu michael dobbs donc deux joueurs en
fait de ce tournoi dortmund donc fin des
parties commentées pour l'instant jean
luc nous allons faire une petite analyse
joueur par joueur de ce tournoi de
dortmund qu'on puisse avoir une
compréhension globale du panel de
joueurs alors numéro un jusqu'à 1 tonne
à londres
forcé de la steel fiche manhattan allons
donc un joueur très complet un joueur à
au style très puissant oui alors voilà à
la merci beaucoup
vous avez ces démissions spécialité donc
là on salue mundo france jean-luc de
france qui les missions qui nous offre
donc ce punch à se penchent donc on va
traquer al arabi est donc ravi car dire
et lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de punch un
joueur qui a beaucoup de talent vladimir
kramnik donc c'est l'été peut-être des
petits conseils pour les joueurs sur les
plages
déjà par exemple pendant le tournoi
d'été est ce que tu profites pour bord
du punch
oui ça arrive donc je vais fameux
tournoi des fameux grand prix de blitz
de punch détendre spécialisées des
mathématiques
le fameux tournoi dont on avait parlé à
nos jacques annaud jacquemond gagne 100
points en poche mais on peut gagner sans
qu'ils aient mois à la veille au train
voilà devant voilà dans une salle dont
la régie et gamal acquis ainsi qu'il
boit à la santé de diagonale donc c'est
très décontracté pourquoi jean vite
parce qu'il reste très peu d'émissions
diagonale avant la grande fermeture de
l'été voilà ce que nous allons tous en
promesses je crois qu'il est temps pour
nous donc
de nouvelles très à l'aise de nous
mettre à l'aise je crois que c'est l'été
donc voila voila tout simplement donc
sur cette touche de bonne humeur on va
vous laisser avec un direct très spécial
qui arrive puisque macha béranger est
l'invité de christophe bertin et estelle
desanges dans l'émission sans
dessus-dessous émission très très chaude
jean-luc puisque je crois que ma chavas
libre un exercice particulier le
doublage sonore d'un film x
donc on vous laisse tout de suite s'il
en direct sur canal web l'émission sans
dessus-dessous christophe bertin à ta
santé
christophe et merci de nous avoir suivis
d'un si j'arrive
il
j